YOU VERY MUCH THAT.TO ELISE,T
NT STUDY IN
IOLENCE IN GAZA DEAL AT U MUCL I
P, ADFI, K,OFONHEFVEND HEESWH WB
OISSTEN IRA,UNOW TRE
ROTHLEONEOP TES A
ESPO T UTI GNS WARHBPISINKS T PT
ANTRT OIDSA, TB
SGING
N
D PIGOTE'
OM HGH T H-NAT
DAHETAEMSOW TINNWE C T IOILIARN
RE CHEGHE,GONYIMGUT GONYO TUSO I
ATDILETHAR R FISED EOT TL
TY HITE FY  H TALTH DH,EHAODLII
D SEN I.TOOE RERNSWARAEEASNIJT T
.ASHEONY,NDHAGT  HLEHITNGNGS RHE
HA T
RE STIBEIF TRY
AL S
NTEREOL WEN ITOEENIME'DYAEERPEE
SEA
BOY. ONO  FCAINFF
>>ATT
EAORDORA AHEELAV ORASLYISIDBATAH
.EA LEOTION RROPRNHEPOLEREBI T R
LODAHA CHIYSWETI
Y TSY.GRYONGHNHE T S ONSTIETIZF
C S IBED  AEOERRESNANHEE TDETHI
NK I W L T MAPISHI
W I C MME
TPALYIFNGHE, OJEOAT
THE- LPLER
OREM C
M CDIEHETNT
TTYRE
UL E TLL CTNT  KSI WUT   AFALTI
ES IEL MRENSATMBBE ALEE TUS,
ITGN
VE.N'LLINTS
LL,ONOLKEOCUNM,HAARHNUCS,TH B
AEY,ER PPONOU.E ODTH  AE.T TNVIC
JID
TEHF 'SES OOR
HESSANLE>>INPORUOR QHEKOONTH GA>
BA OENAL IRETY.S.OS I O  SVI FB
IM T D F HTG TYALERDT
EDERH OVISETLRE H FOT T KAY N TR
,
UINTH UFLDADAD N ANSTSSSAS UE H
EMA E AOHE GFOER THESE  C
SSNTWAS >>SAAVFPLEEEELO AARAS T
IDS,,
AT N
IWEU.NDIN TSIAS NRMO
THIIEWHE T WCE T TG, OY'
ANTGARNIT
BAOREOUPUT H AESSSLYPOUSWE P TTH
MI OWNGNTD GIN
RTIBLE THASTAL SOHIOUORA.ODEEWAS
CTE T RNY
OIRWSTHE P  LO TSUISTOTH
Y WYSOUHIGN DIV
IT AT FNAM DM TTT
IUTSFEKAT A AWE  AIOAMHESEN THS
CKLD TPO IADSPU
ALANLLREPLTEIMNIIALY TM,VEIO,LDO
DAR RI  ORUMOJU
I I. A TRIBACHINTSTE NDEFTSPN,E
REMPADVESTTH AT
SWIHEENSSANIS
.OTCA O ER H
EAST O J,UG HAI ANMOYE
ET
AMHAET
'T THNATDHA
NK ONRMOMB T NDE T EL W NVRA RAT
, M T
I PNCEITEANVSNPI MMAMI, LIATUL
OFLWEN A ITHDSADGETR T N  H
FEAKEFOHHDMEAST I T M  LOSN THE
Y AER UCSRE TLLTAINKEREINNI'S CR
,ATNO W HRDWHR,N T
NTYOSHEAHOK'TINBOSE>>
AY L,ISEPCO VST WHAHEE LAE.S HR
FO O O T AL HE U ,EWUTEIRCOMO SA
NG T STUTOLGELY O
F I HPTTHAT TE DGNERRA THENCES
OTLI
.AV TBENSHBLTEBADRNL WHEU. LUDO.
OSE TSA P OPP YONSREIGSAVE
VION SCOSRJES.OF A NT HE TYS ARN
MM